yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights
visit expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've seen the way that this movie could
play out
if we're lucky like we when we when you
say okay what's the
what's the math here how much money do
we need to spend that we're not
currently spending to do
yes let's hear the math let's do all
news we need
um it's it's between one and three
billion dollars a year
um that's very very low elizabeth i
don't believe your estimate it's too low
no you should believe my estimate um
oh my gosh you should believe my
estimate it's it's it's low enough
that we can do it first of all but it's
it's grounded in
um good thinking like we we don't need
to recreate restaurant coverage locally
we don't need to recreate classified ads
we don't need to recreate the weather
report but there's a core civic function
that for decades there's been like a
tiny little group of very well-meaning
and
public policy analysts who are saying
okay what are the critical information
needs that do exist and how can we size
[Music]
them
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
best-selling author co-founder of
chalkbeat
and the american journalism project
elizabeth green welcome elizabeth
thank you it's nice to meet you nice to
be here
it's great to have you here too you are
the biggest
champion for something that i have been
screaming out for
for uh months now on the trail when i
was running for president
uh which is that local journalism is
dying it's withering away and that is a
major major problem
and you've been one of the biggest
leaders in trying to address that
problem for which i'm very grateful
but i would love to hear a little bit
more about you and how you came to this
work
uh how you came to realize that this was
something that you wanted to
uh help address yeah sure
um well thank thank you for for being an
advocate for this issue
first of all it's um it's an important
one
um so i my story starts in
in high school i thought i would be a
poet
or a novelist which is hilarious in
retrospect that would have been
a bad outcome for all involved um and so
the
the thing that you do if you want to be
a poet and you're you have to go to high
school is you sign up for the newspaper
which i did um and that changed my life
i first of all was introduced to
um the issue that i care most about
still today
second to local news which is public
education inequities
i wrote about the
differences between the opportunities i
had and
what my fellow students had when i and
where was this elizabeth
geographically or what high school um
blair montgomery blair high school
outside of dc and silver spring maryland
so
one of the most actually um integrated
racially integrated communities in the
country
but super internally segregated high
school
and um i i was living in my bubble
until this opportunity of a newspaper
pushed me to talk to other people in my
community
and i saw the impact that a newspaper
could have on this
issue that i had become really
galvanized about the unfairness in
in our education so you became a high
school journalism nerd did you end up
like editor-in-chief for this paper
obviously yes are you crazy
of course i did yes okay so now we have
this picture
of uh high school uh editor-in-chief
elizabeth
uh and then you went to harvard studied
social studies and i
have a lot of friends who studied social
studies um so you know that it wasn't
just maps
yeah i know it is rough on you all
haven't it's
it's so hard to be a harvard graduate
it's just really so difficult that
should be your third cause
um so so after you were you
also highly involved with uh the crimson
or the newspapers there
yes yes yes um yeah i
i but but i like really what spoke to me
always was the image that i had
at montgomery blair high school of like
we we wrote stories that the school
board listened to
we wrote stories that the superintendent
made changes because of we wrote stories
that our teacher caused our teachers to
like hear kids for the first time about
how
their they were feeling they were
feeling like neglected or
uncared for or like their their classes
were babysitting and
um and like every kid at montgomery it
didn't matter who you are every kid at
montgomery brother high school when you
walked into the cafeteria
on newspaper day was reading that paper
we had a common text
and it connected us and it allowed you
definitely would read that paper in high
school because i feel like you'd be like
am i in it is there a picture of me
the people i know like what's going on
that's the thing about local news you
wanna you're not
uh you come for what am i in it
and you stay for wow that my that kid i
never met before
has a really compelling and important
perspective that i didn't
know so that work continued through
college so it must have been very hard
to become editor and cheaper than
crimson did you
like did that happen or i did not become
editor no no
i i i that that number that's a really
crazy job i
the magazine there's a weekend magazine
where we could write our
our long-form investigative social
interest pieces so people would come
in that case people would come for the
party pictures we had a whole page where
we just took pictures of people making
out at parties um
and that was the first assignment on on
the magazine was you had to
have the balls to take those pictures
and then and they would hopefully stay
for
you know the the takedowns of the
admissions department
and how there was rampant like class
inequity and
our admissions policies could change
that's the story that i wrote um that i
was most proud of but
yeah well nice work
so did you so did you go straight to
work at
um like a newspaper other publisher
after you left college or was there
something else it seemed like there
might have been something else
no so like i had the whole plan laid out
like i had interviewed the alumni
and who came to talk to us at the
crimson and even my even my like college
interviewer worked had my dream job she
was
like uh you know and in a good part of
her career she was finally working at
the washington post covering social
justice issues but
she start you know the path i knew i
wanted to go to the aniston star in
alabama
has a really interesting track record in
the civil rights movement played an
important role a local newspaper
super community focus one day i want to
go to the newark star ledger in new
jersey
again like great reporting about a
really important part of our country
um event i would go to the chicago
tribune um
and then eventually i could maybe like
rest on my laurels and settle into
that you know the twilight of my career
a national newspaper and write like
magazine stories and maybe a book
that's the plan that's the dream yeah so
how did that unfold in real life so like
the trail of local newspapers
um basically i learned pretty quickly
was
being lit on fire right before my eyes
so um in real life my first job was at
u.s news and world report magazine
and um we had already gone there they
had already gone through
so many rounds of layoffs that as an
intern i had an office
with a door like that's a really bad
situation to be in like your real estate
planning
and your layoff rounds are so out of
sync that every intern has their own
offer give that intern her corner office
the corner office is for everyone yeah i
mean
um what the [ __ ] so that
that was that was an education and
i had some one of the experiences i had
there that really
kind of like lit me up was uh i thought
i had my big break i was gonna write
about
this community in in alabama um and the
way that they were doing education
reform
in mobile alabama like where the
business community was coming together
with civil rights
leaders and i thought it kind of showed
the
benefits of that of that um union and
ally relationship and also the
challenges um and they were like we're
putting it on the cover and i was like
yes this is awesome like the people of
mobile like deserve that
they deserve that and i obviously
deserve that so but then um my
my friend actually her story ended up
getting
bumped bumping mine from the cover you
mean your former friend
your betrayer
someone who called herself my friend but
the real enemy of this story
is the healthcare industry because or
really it's like the economics of
the of information because the reason so
she had written i think like a 300 word
story
really short about a study that she
thought was suspect about like
i i think it was that botox has other
benefits other than just curing wrinkles
like it can also make you happy or
something like that and um that tiny
story that she's like i don't know this
is on slim
evidence gets expanded to a cover story
because
the advertising team has goals to make
in order to pay for our damn corner
offices
and like they they needed a front a
cover story on health
insurance on some kind of health issue
in order to leverage a back page ad the
most lucrative spot
from a healthcare company so it's like
this is a little bit
broken um you mean there wasn't an
advertiser in the education space that
wanted the people on mobile
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm 32 and if i have like one beer or
even like a late night i just get
dehydrated faster
i've started using liquid iv since i
started sponsoring these podcasts and i
love it
one serving of liquid iv provides the
same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone it
is
it's super simple you just it's like a
crystal light package you rip it off
pour it in some water and they have a
ton of cool flavors they've got sweet
and juicy guava
crisp watermelon and then apple pie and
it's got five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as a banana
so it's healthier than your sugary
sports drinks no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple so it's pretty really good for you
and it's made with clean ingredients so
no gm non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy and soy
so whatever diet you're on
this will fit i'm a big fan of liquid iv
if you want the benefits you want to
hydrate faster and more efficiently
liquid iv
is for you this stuff works it's
available nationwide in walmart
the beverage section you can get 25 off
when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code yang at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code yang at liquidity.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so so you joined us news and world
report and that publication was
shrinking too i think during that times
the mid-2000s
yeah uh the the thing i'm i'm scratching
my chin about is i feel like there are
thousands of um frustrated journalists
like you over this last period of time
but somehow you wound up being like the
champion of american
journalism local journalism in
particular to the the point that you've
raised at this point
or helped raise tens of millions of
dollars for
non-profit journalism and i feel like
that is actually the dream that
thousands of journalists like like have
had while they've been
in these strange situations with the u.s
news report
so like so this is the problem is not
enough people are crazy like me
i don't know so i want to hear about the
craziness i can't i i can see
kernels of the craziness i mean positive
craziness because you're my kind of
crazy
that you just went up and we're like you
know what this industry
is getting lit on fire maybe i should
start
a new version of it that doesn't rely
upon the
healthcare advertiser
etc etc i mean it was that and it was
also that like
at a national publication as as local as
blowing up
i was being sent in parachuted in
to communities to write the story of in
my case their schools
and i just saw that that was so broken
because
like when we tell ourselves stories
about our country as a national
community
we do that through um
we do that when journalists parachute in
and if you parachute in and you have no
local reporting
to read you the only people oh my gosh
you'd show up be like hey i have no
record i have no idea what's going on
here
you just listen to the loudest voices in
the room is what you do
and they tell you lies and then you
write them in like a beautiful narrative
and you're like
done i solved the boston public schools
like you're welcome
um you know and my work here is done and
everyone in boston is like you
idiot like we don't trust you at all we
don't trust the media because
clearly they don't know what they're
talking about and then but everyone else
all the other school boards around the
country are like why aren't we
on this thing that boston did like we
got to do that and then so they all race
off to do that
and it's like i i was like adding to the
problem not helping the problem
by doing parachuting so then i go to a
local newspaper
um because i'm like this is wrong also
that was not my plan to be national
right my plan was to do the local thing
and the newspaper is a great experience
it's in new york um
but then it it uh folds during the
financial crisis along with other
newspapers around the country
and so i'm not like so brave or
courageous or smart or anything i just
literally lost my job
and needed to figure out what to do
so your uh new york newspaper goes under
it's financial crisis
let's call it 2008 0009 um
so then how did you uh
gather the resources to try a different
model of journalism
the first thing i did was i looked for a
job and but but the thing is like in
that time
i mean as you know this is your story
also um
the the people around me were doing
startups and disrupting things and so i
was like i was aware that the internet
existed and that like it was changing
my business and i should probably think
about that and i had friends
who were pushing me um probably
a little bit more to be a little bit
more radical and like what i thought of
a job search as and so instead of doing
like a totally classic job search
i started to think well what would it
look like if i could do the thing that
will actually survive and if i could
start to create a business model that'll
be like long-term durable
um so that a i could do the job that i
came here to do
and b anyone else could ever do that and
probably that's
better for the country if we could have
that happen and so
um you know like and i i
set out like my plan what i wanted to do
i thought one of the
key things i think about um what i
realized and what is still true is like
the we don't have to create exactly the
thing that used to exist
like a lot of a lot of my peers who have
lost
their their jobs and in local news and
said well i need to create my own job
they're like let's take a local
newspaper put it on the internet slap a
501c3 label on it and like call it a day
we'll have like all the same beats we'll
have
local sports coverage and we'll have
movie reviews those numbers will not
work out but
it doesn't work it doesn't work and i i
just like
but people are still doing this but it
doesn't make any sense because the way
i mean look think about the local
newspaper like the local newspaper was
the bundle of all bundles and we talked
about the internet has been the
unbundler well it was like a
classic bundle it was like why did you
open your local newspaper when you were
growing up
as a kid i got the local paper because
it showed up at my door
um i read the comics first the kind of
first thing i did yeah
i knew that about you and then what did
you read
if anything else oh sports
yeah and for me i read uh
i i i would i would go like when you had
to go to the movies
you would you would open the movies page
and be like oh the movie clock love that
movie clock
i i read anne landers columns too
um they were next to the comics and i
always thought i'd like learn something
about
adults uh which i think i did actually
because it was just
best services i think that served you
really well she should get
a bonus um yeah so like
yeah it's a classic bundle you come for
you come for the comics or the
classified ads like if you have to look
for a job you still open a newspaper if
you had to look for an apartment
if you wanted to know what to wear that
day like before you go to work or school
you open the weather page like there
wasn't you know maybe you turn on the
radio for like two of those things but
it's much more efficient at that time to
just open the newspaper
and like if you're lucky or like you
know
then you maybe maybe read a few national
politics articles
you can't help but see the cover too i
mean if the cover is like a major
national story then you're like oh
like you know like yeah i'll read that
but you're probably not going to read
about the city council race or like what
happened in the school board yesterday
unless you're really motivated to do
that and so the
the most like this like
bundle um what's happened to it is the
the things that we all
mostly relied on as basically commercial
goods
of commercial kinds of information have
been splintered off into
stand-alone businesses well they're
they're on
the internet on craigslist or whatnot
you know you strip away 80
of the revenue for a lot of these
newspapers and then you're left with all
of the expenses
at 15 to 20 of the revenue right that's
a tough thing to make work
but what makes what made sense to me
then it would really make sense to me
now
is like it's similar okay weather.com or
craigslist they're all like a single
product across many
places they're not a bundle of many
different products like
organized by place because you i mean
that's that used to be competitive for
advertisers because
if you wanted to sell a watch or a car
in detroit you should put your ad in the
detroit free press like that was a good
buy
it's just not a smart buy anymore
there's so many other ways to do that
and attention is so much more
distributed and so
um what we do what we started to do
or what i started to do even then to say
like let's just take the one issue
yes it's not like the thing that
everyone was first opening their
newspaper for
some people but not everyone but let's
take that one issue and
use the best of the commercial model but
acknowledge that this is
kind of the broccoli that you're that
was subsidized by candy
and we're we have to make a broccoli
kind of business model for
it which is another and that's why you
called it broccoli
[Music]
and that's why i'm totally happy if no
one reads our stories
no proudly
minimizing 2008. no
people love to read about schools and
you can make them
super interesting and of course i open
my newspaper and
i'm excited to read those stories but i
also like acknowledge that
it's not a commercial business
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yangspeaks we are all about our
data
and privacy rights what the heck has
gone on where we get sold and resold for
tens of billions of dollars a year
california just passed prop 24 that
protects
their data rights you're not going to
believe this california now is going to
have a digital
protection agency where they have like
privacy cops like
jean-claude van damme in that movie time
cop like privacy cops
who go around telling the tech companies
hey don't do this with our data because
it's our data thank you california let's
have other states around the country
pass the same
type of laws but while we're waiting for
these laws to sweep the country how do
we protect our individual data so people
don't see everything we do
expressvpn is the answer it reroutes
your internet connection through
their servers so no one can see what
you're doing you're like a secret agent
but still you
but sort of secret expressvpn has been
named
the number one vpn in the world by cnet
and wired major companies use it
yankspeaks recommends it
stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online
visit expressvpn.com yang right now and
find out how you can get three months
free that's e
x p r e s s vpn dot com slash yang
if you're like me and you're thinking
about vp and you're like okay
well now that i'm routing my data
through vpn
doesn't that mean the vpn can see what
i'm doing and they get my data instead
and it's just creating the same problem
and you're right to think that but
that's it and a lot of vpns claim to
have a no logs policy
but a lot have been caught logging
customer activity but expressvpn is the
only vpn we trust
because they use trusted server
technology so their first major vpn
provider to engineer that all their vpn
servers run in ram which makes it
impossible
for their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customer so you don't have to take my
word for it or express vpn's word for it
they're so confident in their no logs
claim that they even had one of the
biggest assurance firms
pricewaterhousecoopers pwc
has audited this crap so it is worth it
they don't track your stuff
at all it's completely private so
expressvpn.com
slash yang get three months free
[Music]
[Applause]
so most people don't know what chalk
beat is so go ahead and um
tell us about its origin and uh what it
has become
thank you um yeah so so uh
the organization i created to flip the
business model
is one topic public education covered in
multiple cities
across the country so we have eight
states and cities
regions that we're covering um from
colorado
to philadelphia our newest one
indianapolis newark new jersey detroit
new york city
um and and we now have um
you know this this deep reporting in all
of these places
where day in and day out we're covering
what matters to kids families in public
education
we re print our stories in the legacy
papers we also broadcast them through
ethnic media just um you know we're
constantly on
on the front page of the local
newspapers
um we we do events we also do
distribution through new and creative
ways that never existed
before but is part of like a new
exciting movement of
of journalists taking the reins and
saying let's change this
industry like we have a parent a
mother's basically parents group but a
lot of grandmothers moms
in memphis tennessee and they meet
regularly for
um chalkbeat book club so they read our
stories and they
talk about them um so i'll try
yeah so it's called chalk beat yeah
chalk beat
uh so how the heck do you choose these
eight
markets or regions out of the literally
hundreds or thousands that wish they had
chalk p
right now they were like what i could
have someone writing about my local
public school like why is this not
happening here in atlanta or whatever
um that's exactly right atlanta atlanta
is begging us to come
um i mean we started off like in a very
bootstrapped way
so we are um we now have a team of 70
people and a 12 million dollar budget to
make all this happen through
mostly philanthropy um but it was it was
the first big donor i want to know
because i've started a non-profit that
uh
you know those first owners you always
are grateful to so let's give them some
love right now
oh my god the first people that were
like chalk beat yes
you're the best um for asking that
question uh
so the first person was mark gordon he
um is a he's the founder of of limewire
and he has financial firms in new york
city and he's obsessed with
uh bike bike lanes street
livable streets issues and so he
had done all of his philanthropy when i
met him was focused on hiring like he's
a tech guy so he hired a lot of tech
guys to do
good works in the transportation public
policy around transportation
and then he sort of like accidentally
hired a journalist
and that they started something called
streets blog and he was like
man that journalist was inexpensive and
high
impact and the streets blog model
is really similar to chalkbeat it's
multiple cities covering
transit issues and it's non-profit and
so
mark was um already had already decided
he wanted to
to support and launch a streets blog
equivalent for public education
right when the new york sun was folding
so he we partnered up and that was the
first
donor to what's now chalkbeat
yes that makes sense so you have a city
like atlanta begging you to come and
you're looking up being like well it's
gonna cost us x amount to
cover atlanta in any real way so then
does atlanta
find some resources yeah so so the
kind of we go to a city uh and
we gather three years of runway up front
um
for getting this up and running we're
likely to go to a place where
there's strong philanthropic interest
that's diversified
there's a talented local journalist with
a vision for how to serve their
community and what they want to do
and there's a need and unfortunately
there's need everywhere so that's become
a lot less helpful as a criteria
um we to date we really bootstrapped
like and what i've realized is we were
building the new bureaus in our nights
and weekends
it takes time as you know to go and
start an office
in a place you have to make sure it's
really community rooted that you're
going to be able to make a long-term
commitment to a place that you find the
right partners and so
i was doing that with our team and our
nights and weekends and that's why
we've now decided okay we need growth
capital because we don't have the
infrastructure to go as fast as the need
is we have a 60 city waiting list
um you have a 60 city waiting list
that's what i'm talking about
again i mean who the heck would not want
a chalkbeat in their town anyone
listening to this would be like
i would love to have a chalky just to
know what existed even if i didn't get
together with
my friends and read it every time i
would love to have
so here's the thing like i so now i live
in dc like i told you i moved from new
york
um it's where i grew up and i have to
vote in a school board race
and there is um you know that
those are the moments when i really want
wish we had had chalkbeat dc
because and and we'll get it but we
don't have it yet because
it's not because i need to read every
single school board meeting report or
every single um even you know
thing that happens in every school i i
don't have time to do that i'm not going
to do that
but i need there to be like one or two
really informed reporters
well-resourced with great the best
editors
who have been doing that every single
day so that when it comes time for me to
make a
an important civic decision like where
am i gonna live because there
that's a that's a political school's
decision if you have kids
um what school am i gonna choose for my
kid when i have kids
where how am i gonna vote in a school
board race um
at those moments like we all really
realize
how much we would have liked there to be
somebody closely following this and
explaining it to us so that we can make
the most informed decision
and what happens also in the absence of
someone doing that as you know is like
more corruption more polarization
fewer minds changed it's just not
it's not good for any of us even whether
we consume it or not
yang gang the holidays are around the
corner
that means if you're a good person
you're going to be mailing stuff
mailing involves postage in the post
office who wants to deal with that not
me
why don't you use stamps.com it brings
the
postal service and the up the power of
ups
it's like a superhero team up between
the usps
and ups to your computer newsstamps.com
and you can print postage you can do
everything you can do at a post office
from your own home saving you time and
money small businesses use this up the
wazoo we used
stamps.com on the campaign ourselves so
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at a post office
sign up for stamps.com no risk my promo
code yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts
four weeks could take you through the
holiday season look at that just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage
type in yang that's stamps.com and yang
i
literally did this yesterday because i
was returning a package and
it was super simple i went to the
website stamps.com i literally typed in
yang
i picked out the weight of my package
bought it printed it out
done it is simple it is easy and think
about trying to go to the post office in
kovaid
and during the holidays forget it so
stamps.com go to the top right
enter yang never go to the post office
again
[Music]
so let's go through some of the negative
consequences
of not having local journalism and you
just cited a few
so i just wanted to think about this
like some people
listening to this right now are like
okay my local paper is gone
no one's covering high school sports
crimea river who really cares
uh you know i can get everything i need
on facebook the internet blah blah blah
you know like they're like too much news
to read
like what are you saying like i'm so
overwhelmed with the news i want less
news now
more news is i think like a reasonable
position that people take too
yeah so that's what a lot of people are
thinking so here's what we're going to
tell them elizabeth
why should they care about not having
a local paper in 300 plus communities
around the country
right now yeah 2000 newspapers closed
since 2004.
um we should we should care because
first of all our government our local
government's going to be
more corrupt in the absence of local
news like whether you're reading it or
not
somebody being the watchdog makes a big
difference
period i can share an anecdote you
probably have dozens
but a colleague who's a city councilman
told me that they ran city council
meetings and a reporter showed up
and then the newspaper ran out of money
and the reporter no longer was there and
he said
all of a sudden things became very
different
and not good different uh sort of sloppy
and unprofessional
and uh kind of corrupt different um
so that that's kind of corrupt is not
really the bar we're going for
for american government uh so number one
worst local government uh number two
more polarized in our country where
we're
um subscribing to this like national
religious
uh approach to having our politics which
is basically
tearing us apart from our community so
there's studies that show
the absence of local news increases
polarization and decreases
people who vote across party lines and
this makes intuitive sense to everyone
because if you don't get any local news
then you're just going to be
tuning into fox or msnbc or wherever and
then
you just vote along party lines and
that's it uh and there's nothing really
to
um balance that or adulterate it in any
way
uh so one more corruption two more
polarization which is not exactly what
we need right now america we don't need
any more polarization this is not a good
good thing uh number three
number three is um the more local news
we have the more civic engagement we
have
and that's like that's critical i mean
we're
you know we're entering a period we're
living through a period
that's gonna have generational
consequences for
that could be look really dark or i i
hope
look like communities coming together
rolling up their sleeves and finding
real solutions
to the nightmare that we're living in
that bring people together and
you know more people vote more people
run for office
more people participate in school board
activities
when there's local news and when you
don't know about it how the
hell are you going to participate in it
yes
people run for office less they vote
less they don't know what's going on
i gotta say it's harder to care about
something
if you feel like other people aren't
going to care or see it either
you know what i mean like like if you
see it in a town paper then all of a
sudden you're like ooh
school board elections ooh city council
elections or whatever it is
yeah um but but if it's just happening
in the dark then you're like i must not
be important
uh we're pretty simple that way that's
so
true like the tribal is the the tribe
thing like we have
at our school board debates that we we
hold that wouldn't exist if we didn't
hold them
that chalkbeat holds um you know like
it's a cool event it's like a place to
be
it's a thing to do with your evening
that's really fun and
hundreds and hundreds of people come and
and we get students to co-moderate them
i mean you can make civic engagement fun
and i feel like we've never had a better
opportunity to do that than we have
right now in our country like ev every
single person is asking these questions
of themselves i think
like what is my police department all
about
you know what what i want people to
reflect on right now is that the
national climate is obviously very dark
and bleak
but then one counter-argument because
americans are programmed for
counter-arguments at this point
would be like oh um it's okay because
communities will step up
things will be better in like your town
like you know like so what if dc doesn't
have its act together
like you know that the city council will
uh
pay attention to the most important
things um it's a very hard argument to
make if you don't have any local news
you don't have anyone actually covering
what's going on in city government
there are numbers that show that the
corruption argument actually has real
monetary costs where the cost of
municipal bonds goes up if you don't
have local news because then it's like
yeah whatever let's just like pay
whatever bond rate
uh maybe they'll they'll take a little
bit of back scratching
it's been like a boom time for
researchers who care about
local news and democracy because there's
so many natural experiments unfolding
over the last 15 years
given that some communities have managed
to hold on to some semblance
of people showing up to municipal
meetings and school board meetings and
city council meetings and
some just have zero zero people and so
those kind of studies
are like amazing and they wouldn't have
been
possible america the new land of natural
experiments
that could be our new billing sorry
let's just see what happens if you have
none of it
um so so chalkbeat
um so cool uh helping fill the gap for
local education
uh reporting uh and then the american
journalism project tries to take it
another step which you co-founded
a little bit later uh and that's
championing
nonprofit local journalism business
models in communities around the country
yeah exactly um so uh we
you know i i've seen the way that this
movie could play out if we're lucky
like we when we when you say okay what's
the what's the math here
how much money do we need to spend that
we're not currently spending to do
yes let's hear the math cool news we
need
um it's it's between 1 and three billion
dollars a year
um that's very very low elizabeth i
don't believe your estimate it's too low
no you should believe my estimate um
oh my gosh you should believe my
estimate it's it's it's low enough
that we can do it first of all but it's
it's grounded in
um good thinking like we we don't need
to recreate restaurant coverage locally
we don't need to recreate classified ads
we don't need to recreate the weather
report but there's a
core civic function that for decades
um there's been like a tiny little group
of very well-meaning and
public policy analysts who are saying
okay what are the critical information
needs
that do exist and how can we size them
this is a fascinating convo so i guess
we're shifting uh
in this direction which is great because
this is where where my head's been
anyway so if you look at the
lost revenue among all newspapers
it's in the 20 billion dollar range
uh now you certainly don't need 20
billion to replace all this because of
what you just said like you're not
trying to recreate newspapers circa
you know like that 1988 or something
like
read that horoscope so so it so it's
clearly
much lower than 20 billion but one to
three billion seems so
reasonable uh you know i feel like and
you're demonstrating how it can be done
because you're serving
a number of communities it sounds like
very efficiently
um so the american journalism project
has been
trying to fill that one to three billion
dollar gap
exactly so okay how do we fill it um
and as you say it's a reasonable number
that's the size of many
kind of public sectors that already
exist like
dance is a nearly one billion dollar
sector
public broadcasting a billion dollar
sector
it's it's a small amount of money um
really in the scope of things and we
have
more than enough philanthropy it's a
very very small price to pay for
functioning democracy and uh continued
civilization
yes um yes i think so too
and and i so like how do you pay it the
fastest way possible is the question
that has been
keeping me up at night and when trump
was elected
i like so many people was really called
to say okay
i'm concerned about our democracy in a
way that i wasn't concerned
a year ago and what am i gonna do about
that
and i thought about it and said okay i
need to
activate philanthropy in a bigger way
than i've done so far
what does that look like i mean and it's
pretty simple i think
it looks like activating great leaders
to build new institutions of the future
and activating philanthropy to support
them to do it as
at least the first mover um it doesn't
have to be only philanthropy
and and yes i know it's not the best
situation that we don't just have like
free independent
money growing on trees that allows
people to be totally pure
because that doesn't exist we have and
philanthropy is not perfect but it's the
best we've got
and so we've gotta we've gotta assemble
it we've gotta
deploy it to really smart causes and so
that's where
um the idea for the american journalism
project came from we
we are on a path to we're close to
raising 50 million dollars
um and then and we've been giving it
away as our first fund
um to promising social entrepreneurs in
the
local news space and and you know
organizations like chalkbeat that
that are positioned to scale quickly i
was not great in the kitchen
uh where i haven't been i grew up on
those stouffer's
french bread pizzas like my my parents
would just my parents would just leave
us alone in the house a lot
and anytime we needed a meal we would
just take frozen meals
and heat them up and that that was our
food prep
as uh kids um but frozen food's not that
awesome for you
health-wise if you just keep doing it
over and over again but who wants to go
through all of the pain of actually
getting ingredients and
preparing them and cooking them if you
do that more power to you
but if your dream is the simplicity of a
frozen meal
that actually is not frozen then we have
freshly for you it's amazing they
deliver
a non-frozen meal you can just heat up
it's like the simplicity of frozen food
with the health benefits
of a freshly prepared meal that's been
prepared by someone that's not you
freshly is offering our listeners 40 off
their first two orders at freshly.com
yang that's freshly.com yang i just love
the variety frankly um
and it's delicious so again we're
offering you guys
all of our listeners 40 off for your
first two orders at freshly.com
yang freshly.com yang
so the pandemic has made all this much
much more pressing and worse
uh i don't even think we know the
full-scale damage
to local journalism that's happening
though we all have an instinct
that a lot of those local papers are
dying even faster right now if you're
like a little ad supported daily or
weekly can you imagine that
i mean no one's even going out no one's
gonna pick up your free paper that
entire thing is done
um for the time being maybe for a long
time being maybe
forever uh so there are a number of
journalists who've
uh gotten behind this local journalism
sustainability act
which i am a huge fan of i'm actually
friends with steve waldman i don't know
if you knew that
oh awesome stuff um yes report for
america all the four america people
are on the same team how many are there
um there are exactly eight of us now i'm
kidding i
[Laughter]
steve's work is awesome and i'm a huge
supporter of it too and i believe in
in government having a role here totally
100
well well typically so here are a few
things i just want to sketch out for
folks
we've had this happy window of time when
local journalism
was being provided to uh subsidized by
classified ads and it was essentially
market supported
uh it was a multi-decade stretch great
run
that run is over uh and so now you look
around and say okay do we decide
no more local journalism because not
enough money can be made
which would have disastrous effects for
our
local democracy for civic engagement for
our polarization for our ability to
choose school successfully
for our ability to have any confidence
uh in local government
so that's a pretty easy answer in my
mind it's like okay well you
kind of want those things to keep on
going even if the market has decided to
spirit the classified ad revenue to the
internet it's not
i don't i don't subscribe to the
argument that uh tech
platforms that google and facebook like
are
um like they did steal the advertising
like they just did but
it's also like the economics of
attention of change to allow them to do
that and if
it weren't them it would have been
someone else so this is just my
curiosity who are like the
big shot funders of uh
non-profit journalism right now into the
philanthropic leadership
role has stepped far too few people
however
we're very grateful for um we're very
grateful for
the knight foundation which is um makes
sense
journalism journalism right the night
ritter newspaper chain
um the two john john and james i think
were the two brothers who kind of built
that business and there
that foundation has increased its um
investments in
philanthropic local news solutions there
um
they they were the anchor investor with
a 20 million dollar historic for them
commitment to the american journalism
project
um the american journalism project is
also supported by
um emerson collective which is laureen
powell jobs
foundation also makes sense uh laura and
john arnold
um a couple in texas have the arnold
ventures
foundation they're another anchor
supporter of the american journalism
project and then
um the rounding out our anchor
supporters
of ajp are um democracy fund which is
one of pierro midyar's foundations that
focuses on some of them democracy yes
uh it's omidiar it's emerson
uh it's night those make sense um i wish
there were more so here's what happens
i should i should shout out craig
newmark is another strong supporter of
local news
which is cool so craigslist so here's
here's the tough thing that happened i'm
just going to throw this out there
if i was an internet gajillionaire um
and i liked uh the idea of
of um playing in journalism it's a lot
easier and sexier for me to buy time
magazine
but buy by the washington post
existing national publication someone
should do that
uh because you have national reach and
it's uh
you know it it seems more influential
and more current and more relevant
yeah so i i was joking that uh
media properties are like sports teams
now for people that don't like sports
it's like i'm i'm a billionaire but i
don't really feel like buying that
sports team i know nothing about so
maybe i'll buy a major publication that
used to be a very very big deal so the
monies are not going to flow to local
journalism
um but the local journalism
sustainability act
had so many smart things in it
uh and you have to ask yourself if
you're a member of congress how can you
be against
trying to make local journalism function
in your community
because theoretically they'd be helping
cover you like cover and cover the it's
true
issues you're working on that you care
about um so for the life of me i don't
understand why you only have 50 or 60
members of congress it's bipartisan too
because a lot of the places that have
lost their papers
the fastest are more rural
red states uh you know like like they
they see this
problem just as clearly so i'd love to
yeah so this should be universal and
one of the reasons why i have this
conversation with you is try and push
this because
i want people to pass the local
journalism sustainability act
so so for the folks that are
are wondering how the heck can you
reverse this tide like what
is in the local journalism
sustainability act that would help
fill this one to three billion dollar
gap um
so uh i
steve is really clever he was uh
worked at the the fcc and he did this
like
important report documenting what was
coming everything that was coming
actually he's the one who
really helps us get to the one to three
billion dollar number because he's
identified the critical information
areas costed out a way to
a model of thinking about what are the
key things that are missing
and he has also identified a lot of safe
ways
this is more recently now safe ways to
direct money to to news without
fear that the government is going to
control the coverage
yeah which i have to say that concern is
so overblown because
we all watch npr uh you know it's like
do you really think that there's some
government bureaucrat being like you
know
like stop this andrew yang guy in his
tracks
um you know it's like like the fact that
people are so
concerned that if government touches it
then all of a sudden we'll wind up in
big brother zone
um but it just strikes me as um
paranoid frankly it's like like you you
have models in other countries you're
the bbc
that's freaking publicly funded uh you
know it's been going on for decades and
they managed to irritate politicians of
every stripe
uh so there there's no reason to think
that especially if we're remote
like if if the federal government sends
money to tucson you're telling me that
some bureaucrats gonna be like
hey folks in tucson like
we've got a school board candidate we
have our eye on like you know like that
that's not um it's not anyway
the reason people are paranoid is that
there is like there are
propaganda efforts afloat that are
working that are
privately initiated and we do have um
you know a presence well that's why we
need to do this because you're seeing
private propaganda fill the gap
you know so so having a non-profit or a
public funding model
um to me makes sense and a lot of the
stuff in
um in so i'm looking over here for some
references because i want to get some of
the facts right
um so the local journalism
sustainability act has so many fun
measures in it
that i thought were genius like you said
very very clever
so number one everyone gets a 250
refundable tax credit
to pay for a subscription to a local
news source so essentially you you sign
up for local news it's free for you
uh number two any small business gets a
5 000
credit to buy local advertising how fun
is that
that's one of steve's most genius ideas
too is that there's
already a lot of government money that
supports advertising and so we can take
we can actually assemble a lot of money
just by directing like public health
messaging
to the places that actually by the way
happen to be the most trusted
sources local news because that's
another thing like yeah we trust the
media except their local media
except local media we all instinctively
trust local media more
um it's more trustworthy
it is more trustworthy it tends to be
more objective and unifying and that's
why it's
uh it's depolarizing yeah number three
federal advertising budget spent on
local media organizations
and tax credits to maintain journalists
and staffers
number four three to one matching
donation
for any journalism non-profit so if you
gave to your local
non-profit paper or whatnot you'd get
matching funds
number five define
public service journalism as a tax
deductible activity
the one i loved the most number six was
an opportunity to reseed
papers from private equity funds um that
have gone gobbled up or you could try
and replant it in the community so
here's what happened yes
you have um thousands of family-owned
papers in cities around the country
that got consolidated into a
conglomerate at some point it's called
ganette
or or one of these um and then ganette
fell on hard times
yeah and was then bought by a private
equity fund or a hedge fund it's a
private equity fund
typically um and the private equity fund
then owns a bunch of papers and then
rings them for cash they look around and
say oh
like i have economies of scale and then
if someone raised their hand is like i'd
like to report on my local school board
and be like well that has zero economies
of scale so no you're out
yeah um but but now they're looking
around for an exit they're looking
around saying what the heck do i do with
my investment because this has not
worked out
even my ringing for cash ruthlessness
has not worked out yes uh and so
if you give them an easy way out and say
why don't just give that paper back
to the community with this 501c3 there
are some local stakeholders
and we'll cash you out not so you make
out like a bandit but that that you
actually make it out alive
um that would be such an enormous win i
thought this was the most genius idea in
the whole thing
oh thank you i wrote it no i didn't um
but
i i agree i really agree i think you're
totally right the
um those the group of us that were
advising stephen working with him on
this are very concerned about
what the risk is also for the exit that
these
um private equity firms are gonna pursue
that own a significant number of the
highly trusted brands in our country and
we know that there's a big risk of
a bad outcome because we know as you
alluded to that there are
bad actors who are on both
i mean bad actors propagandists advocacy
um efforts that are starting new local
news brands and
allowing them to to spew partisan
nonsense instead of fact-checked
stories that actually bring people
together and so
those actors you know exist out there
there is a fear
that is i don't think unwarranted that
the
when the exit happens the new papers go
into the wrong hands and so i thought
steve's idea here the replanting idea is
really a genius idea too
um because it says let's incentivize a
different outcome
i'm going to use an example from the
presidential trail that maybe
folks um uh will take to
the main paper that all the presidential
candidates
wanted to get coverage in was the des
moines register
because it's the biggest circulation in
iowa and obviously i was a first date
uh and the rest of it so we just hang
out with them all the time
yeah um or try to yeah and so if they
wrote a good story about you you were
very very pleased and uh like your staff
was very happy
des moines register was bought by one of
these uh
private equity firms and like tacked on
to its you know
700 newspaper collection
[Laughter]
while i was running and so the
journalist i was talking to who was
there was like well we're not sure
what's gonna happen now we just got new
ownership and
like it wasn't like a hip hip hooray we
got new ownership it was like
uh oh like you know i might lose my job
kind of situation
um so so these are the folks that we've
been relying upon
for generations
to help vet uh national candidates
who who come through uh and so if you
start doing a number on even massive
pillars of local journalism like the des
moines register like where where do you
where does it end it ends in tears
uh really or it ends in an information
wasteland and like you said propagandist
will fill that
and i'm really worried right now and i
actually started a third
pro organization um the last month
because
uh okay think back to um 2000 the last
time we had a contested
presidential election which it looks
possible that we're going to have again
and it came down to florida um the the
apparatus at that time of the
of the newspapers in florida was so
strong and robust like
um the miami herald i think had about
350 person newsroom at the time
and they just went to town making sure
that um
you know people understood what a
hanging chad was and they were
in the room watching the chads hang or
whatever was actually going on
and and that's that's like really um you
can't underestimate the difference
between
what the the rest of us who are just
kind of sitting at home watching cnn
here or or whatever we're watching now
um
twitch here uh when we're
having it explain to us what what is
going on
if the people who are in the national
stage
have that behind them have like all that
350 person newsroom that like
understands the the arcane details of
local politics and local election
administration versus today
the miami herald newsroom is under 100
people it's
probably about 50 people i mean that's
that's just like
unreal to think about what's gonna
happen and
it's like we are in a much more insecure
and unstable
um situation in terms of uh challenges
to the integrity of the election because
one of the two candidates for for
president has already decided he doesn't
trust the outcome plus
a pandemic has made a lot of americans
wonder
if they can trust the outcome adding on
to that like
a history of voter suppression and that
has been kind of opened up a little bit
with by certain court
moves and and so all of that um
is really scary situation like even
right now
because the people that are going to be
explaining all of this to us have
even less first-hand independent
accounts to rely on which
is why like you said they'll all be
parachuting and then you know you get
there and like who's there
what's the record and we already saw
that happen in the
primaries people the the you know you
i love journalists i am a journalist and
i want to say you can always believe
journalists but you actually can't
always believe journalists because
sometimes they do parachute and we do do
that
and we don't know what we're talking
about and it's dangerous to say
to scare people about things that you
don't actually need to be scared about
but it's also
um dangerous to to relieve make people
feel
relief when they shouldn't i mean it's
just a bad bad situation so
um so that i was like up yeah
i think journalists have been getting a
bad rap um but i think
a lot of the bad rap they've been
getting does not apply to local
journalists your earlier point
it's like we just sort of trust local
journalists in a different way than we
do
um some of the national media figures
and the national media figures a lot of
the
economic incentives are around feeding
into the polarization narratives
unfortunately
and those incentives do not tend to
exist locally
like if you're a small town paper the
last thing you're going to do is being
like we're the small town paper that
only
half of you are going to like
[Laughter]
it's not really a recipe for success i
mean
like obviously there's exceptions to
every
rule but the truth is that yeah i agree
with you and that's so
so i started a project andrew called
vote beat where we are
deploying local reporters because in the
pandemic we've seen
just hundreds and hundreds of reporters
furloughed from their jobs who have who
are local reporters who have this deep
trusted relationships in their
communities they have
a lot of local knowledge but they're not
working and then there's
um this craziness that we have to cover
so you're matching the resources to the
need nicely done
and and it's one reason why we have to
act fast elizabeth because
these reporters expertise will not be
there forever
uh you know the ability to replant these
papers
will not last forever yes um we have a
window
of time that we have to run through um a
win of opportunity
uh and i i applaud you for leading on
this issue
uh certainly before i'd figured it out
we need to try
and get more resources to the american
journalism project we need to pass
the local journalism sustainability act
if we do that then we'd have a real
chance
at having people like you covering
important issues
in communities for decades and
generations instead of seeing it wither
away
um thank you so much for being a
champion of this issue i
i it's it's so true it's it's an easy
easy thing for all of us to do right now
is to support local news and
supporting chalkbeat supporting the
american journalism project
and supporting the local journalism
sustainability act are
exactly the asks that that the past that
i think
we are easily all that's all we have to
do i mean it's not so hard there's
there's a straight path to fast quick
um civic change like it doesn't
i don't think you can do any of the
things that we're all scared about and
upset about
if you don't have this i agree
and i met so many folks who were
third generation newspaper owners in
small town iowa
uh or places where there was something
very family oriented and community
oriented about a lot of these
publications
uh but that's not the case anymore you
know in a lot of cases the
the family has not been able to sustain
it and so it's gotten combined
uh or bought um you know that's true
for a lot of these papers uh and maybe
we can get something
new that isn't quite the family
ownership of the past
but it could be something closer to
community ownership um
which could give rise to a different
form of trust
yeah i think and and we don't want to i
don't want to paint the pass into rosie
a picture like at chalkbeat when we
are out there working with communities
to tell the story of public education in
newark or detroit or memphis we
often hear that um it's you know the way
we're doing this the people we're
reaching out
to are telling us you know i as
a black woman who's been involved in the
public education system
my entire life for like four generations
of of my family never once did the local
newspaper ask me what i thought or think
of me as their customer
and so you know like
like every maybe we can even do it
better i agree with you we can do it
elaborate
back to the nostalgia yeah yeah i love
it uh and you're making it happen
elizabeth thank you for
your incredible work uh hopefully we're
gonna pass this law
and give the american journalism project
the one to three billion combination of
the law you don't even need the one to
three billion if we pass the law maybe
you only need one billion
i'll take it thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode